well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look then of what
is on the front pages
as they arrive in the uh next what is it
20 minutes or so we'll be seeing what's
making the headlines with nancy fielder
editor of the star
and mark wallace chief executive of
conservative home welcome to both few
great to see you
lots to pack in as you might imagine so
let's check out the front pages
telegraph then outlines the prime
minister's roadmap
out of lockdown and counts down 118 days
until freedom the paper tells us
the time says the end is in sight
the 21st of june the provisional end
date for all restrictions
makes the splash for the metro
midsummer's dream
is their headline the financial times
says johnson
insists the end is in sight with summer
targets
to end covet curbs the guardian has the
same story with the prime minister
promising spring and summer will be
incomparably better than life in
lockdown
the mirror says the dates outlined by
boris johnson today will be the
best days of our lives while the eye
sets out the plan as four steps to
freedom
the sun seizing on boris johnson's
cautious approach with the headline
the weight escape the slow road to
unlock down
the daily express says britain is on a
one-way road to freedom
the daily star has its own distinctive
take on today's announcement
from the prime minister and the
sheffield star nancy's paper
simply says chuffed to bits
well chuffed to bits midsummer's dream
uh the metro then we're starting with
nancy
uh data not dates and there we are a
whole range of dates for us to get
excited about
we can't avoid them can we no we can't
it's all about these dates and it's
interesting they're already looking
forward to summer but i think most of us
are just really looking forward to two
weeks when the kids can get back to
school
finally after what feels like a lifetime
for most of them
and we can start to see a friend or two
let alone the end of the month when
things get even better
so i'm a little bit skeptical about
looking forward to june and july at this
stage but i am over the moon as i think
we all
are that we finally got a plan i mean
who knew we had a prime minister who
could produce a
sensible plan led by scientists um
interesting yes i think for me it's two
households getting together
um it's been difficult for the kids that
you can't see a whole family
um and and that's been since the rule of
six on september the 14th so we've all
got something to look forward to which
is
brilliant news whether it should be june
the 21st as the metro says
life goes back to normal is another
matter um the cases are still high
aren't they mark
they are but they're moving excuse me
they're moving in the right direction
i've got to say i'm
particularly excited about the 21st of
june because it's not just the day the
nation gets unlocked
at last it's also my wedding anniversary
so um that's going to be an even bigger
anniversary party although i imagine
it's also going to be quite difficult to
find a restaurant to book anywhere
we'll all just chat about what bits
we're looking forward to shall we
but let's go to the eye now nancy they
say four steps to freedom
those four key dates is there anything
that surprises you in the list
um for example when hairdressers might
be able to get near people for example
what what did you make
of all of it you know what actually
genuinely has taken by surprise is that
it's it's really long
term and it just seems such a really
good plan i mean we've obviously spoken
to people who aren't over the moon about
it and don't think it's fast enough but
we've all been there haven't we been
there and got the t-shirt from what
happens when you rush
and this feels like the opposite of this
so look we would love this to end much
more quickly but i think this
is really really sensible and i think
the hairdressers can plan
even teachers have got two weeks now i
mean we know everything's not clear with
what's going to happen
with the exams and lots of children are
kind of working towards something with a
moving target
but actually getting the schools open is
the big key thing and as you said you
know getting together with your nearest
and dearest
i've had family babies born we've not
even met them yet so all those things
are really really exciting for everybody
yes um the sun with a socking grape
padlock
calling it the weight escape the slow
road to unlock down
48 days until a pint outside a haircut
or a gym visit
83 days until a pint in a pub or fans
back in stadiums
118 days until all restrictions are
lifted at last
so tell me mark why the cautious
approach from the prime minister
why does it seem such a change from last
time has science won
or is it just the volume of misery and
deaths that has prompted him to
to think about how we do this well it
seems to me that there are three
main reasons for the degree of caution
you see here
first is yes frankly they have
they and we and all of us have suffered
the the downsides and
and the ill effects um to a very severe
degree of unlocking
some things too quickly um and also the
government of course has had the
political
experience of over promising and then
being forced to under deliver by certain
by events in the past the second element
is that
they want to have a gap between each of
these changes
in order to be able to gather new data
to see what the actual effect of each
change
is and remember there's still the
different variants and so on
floaty ranch work in different ways and
the third element is of course that
the vaccination program continues and we
know that it's been
very effective we know that uptake's
been really high among those offered it
so far
but there's some sign that the
scientists are uh
edging on the kind of slightly
pessimistic sides about vaccine uptake
among some lower groups which
could of course itself increase the the
risk of reducing restrictions so
there's some leeway in there but i think
it's it's understandable where the
caution comes from yes i'm also dealing
with this new variant the kent variant
with its increased transmissibility
aren't we b117
um to the guardian then nancy um on top
of the
the dates and the metrics for measuring
whether we can progress to the next
level
we also learned today that there are to
be four reviews um for example how long
we need to maintain
social distancing and and face mask
wearing and the guardian points out in a
signal of how different the new normal
will be
from pre-pandemic life covid status
certificates are being considered to
help businesses
reopen and no doubt get people on their
holidays possibly if that happens
and what did you think of those reviews
that are underway
and the prospect of us having to carry
around some proof that we've
either been tested or vaccinated
i actually think right now people just
want a way out and if this is what it
takes and this is what we need to do i
think what mark's already referred to
about the the gaps between each step
is really really sensible and well we
are all really excited
and while the vaccine program has been a
big success
there are variants and you've mentioned
one but we don't know how they're going
to develop so we've just got to be
really sensible about it and he has been
he's been quite clear
that actually if things go wrong we
won't be able to stick to this
but i think today we can enjoy it and we
can look forward and if a certificate is
what you need to be able to go on
holiday then
surely most of us would want that
because we're also desperate
for things to be better and so desperate
to get away a little bit yeah we've got
your
your paper uh the star in sheffield
there chuffed to bits you're saying
um how did this go down in westminster
then how did the the members of the
the tory covid recovery group take the
news
mark sorry that will ask mark that i'll
come back to you about your your front
nancy apologies well you can see that
there is pressure on
from parts of the conservative back
benches in particular to go
faster on this there's there are reports
that there's some pressure from within
the government to go faster than this
and
it is understandable why the fact is
that this has been
a as well as a disastrous medical and
health event it's been a disastrous
economic event and there are people
businesses and jobs
families and and individuals
particularly people actually
living by themselves who are suffering
really badly through all of this and
it's understandable i think that people
are seeking a way to try and get out
faster
the important thing is firstly that this
has to be based on the evidence
and the second thing is the government
equally has to do
the right thing in terms of
demonstrating that it's studying
well if there's any unexpected good news
that comes through the fact is if we
continue to get good news about vaccine
efficacy
if the vote continues to go ahead of
time uh if take
uptake is higher than people expect then
i think it would be reasonable for tory
mps to ask the government to take that
into account
as to whether some of these dates can be
brought forward but we've seen they're
going to be cautious about it
yes and your paper then nancy um you
know the emptiness of the high street
uh is writ large on your front page but
you say big questions from bar owners
and teaching unions
and certainly there have been some
criticisms or concerns raised about all
schools going back
and some had teachers already suggesting
if they do have to test
pupils twice a week then they won't be
ready to get it all done on one day what
what what are your
what are you hearing yeah absolutely
that's what we're hearing from head
teachers
it's a massive operation for them um my
local school's been
so asking for volunteers so that they
can be open ready and they can be doing
the testing
but there's all sorts of things to take
into account the children have fallen so
far behind everybody the disadvantaged
children have fallen further behind and
now we're looking at all secondary
school children wearing math there's
just so much to get
their heads around but also throwing
everybody back in
in one go when i'm not sure that's quite
what teachers are expecting
doesn't make us understand be a little
bit nervous but hopefully we've got that
grace period afterwards
where we can see that it works before we
move on to the next step in terms of the
pubs
a lot of hubs have tiny tiny gardens in
sheffield and many of them are saying to
us
it's just not worth their while opening
until they can open properly
and they're really really hoping that
government support is there
and backs them up so they can get to the
they when they're allowed to be back to
normal
yeah it's sort of urban versus rural for
the benefits of reopening pub gardens
isn't it very difficult for for many in
city centres
um and what about uh the the prospects
um do you think um mark as we go forward
um looking at other newspapers like the
times for example let's just see their
front page
uh the end is in sight um and the
telegraph talking about 118 days
to freedom effectively do people really
believe that do you think
i think people are extremely hopeful of
it and i think there are a lot of
positive signs pointing in that
direction as i say the vaccine roll out
the vaccine efficacy
numbers the studies keep coming back um
in a surprisingly
positive positive way um the the obvious
overall performance of the you know the
national statistics in terms of the
pandemic
it is still i think starting to dawn on
all of us
that just as last spring when we started
to try to grapple with how long this
might last i think a lot of us hope that
it might be over by now equally it is
time to dawn on all of us that there may
yet be
um you know things like vaccine
passports
for travel or for that matter even
requests of masks and that kind of thing
after this date and that's still
something that's quite unclear to a lot
of people
um the the waiting theme uh there are
many people who will be saying
what is the point of this massively fast
vaccine rollout
more doses given than than the entirety
of the european union we learned today
we all have to wait so long four months
to this june date
118 days as the newspapers are saying um
do you think people understand actually
that that
not everybody is vaccinated that not
that vaccines aren't 100 effective
nancy do you think impatience will set
in
i think we're all feeling a little bit
impatient now but actually
most of us understand this and actually
i was speaking to a couple today who
were
in their 70s and they were just like
look we want our son to have it and he's
in his
30s their daughter's in their 40s and
their grandkids are going back to school
they want to be able to get together
safely with everybody
but they understand that them having the
vaccine isn't enough for that and i
think most of us are reasonable we do
understand this we have put with an
awful lot we've had to haven't we
so i think the end is in sight and this
is what will keep us going
and it'd be brilliant the day when
everybody who wants to have the vaccine
and let's hope that's everybody who's
had the vaccine
well chef to bits in sheffield and mark
wallace thank you both very much indeed
nancy thank you